also wenn wir glaube ich das ganze essen
annehmen würden dann sehe ich jetzt
nicht mehr so aus sondern so und leute
was genau jetzt willkommen bei einer
neuen video und zwar geht es heute um
dinge die wir an unserem großeltern
leben ich habe mir für das ganze ein
bisschen unterstützung gold vom lieben
twizy nicht verlinkt euch den einfach
mal am ende aber ansonsten wünsche ganz
viel spaß mit dem video
wenn ihr das recht ihr wenn es euch
gefällt gibt noch nach oben und dann
würde ich mal sagen wir von
logischerweise mit punkt eins an und
zwar kennt ihr das bestimmt alle
vielleicht schon vor zwei oder drei
jahren und zwar ist man ja manchmal
dieser situation da hat man einfach kein
geld mehr für den rest des monats über
und er denkt man sich wo kriege ich denn
jetzt geld ja aus dieser situation kann
man dann wie folgt aus indem man einfach
zu seinen opa und oma gefahren ist halt
einfach so und ja da bekam man irgendwie
mal geld auch wenn man eigentlich gar
kein geld wollte selbst wenn ich nur aus
dem grund da mittag zu essen oder
vielleicht mal zu besuchen dann kriege
ich trotzdem mehr geld obwohl ich
eigentlich gar kein geld auch und davor
dass malawi auf geld bekommen also jedes
mal wenn man dahin fährt sieht das
ungefähr so aus mitzumischen
es ist egal so dann würde ich mal sagen
wir kommen auch schon zu punkt 2 und
zwar haben ja unsere großeltern in ihrem
leben schon ziemlich viel erfahrung
gesammelt sag ich mal
und dieser punkt betrifft vor allem
unsere opas und was ich damit meine ist
das hier bedenken willst du wirklich
stören
jack nicklaus ist von 19 33 als die
strophen waren mit den hübschen und
immer wenn man denkt das muss doch
irgendwann war die letzte geschichte
sein soviel kannst du doch gar nicht
erlebt haben da kommt immer wieder was
neues und das nimmt auch kein ende also
macht euch keine hoffnung aber ist es
auch immer echt unterhalten und vor
allem ganz cool finde ich und dann
kommen jetzt auch schon zum nächsten
punkt und zwar ist das ja so immer wenn
ihr bei euren großeltern seid euch wird
sagen aber alle zehn minuten irgendwas
zu essen angeboten selbst wenn ihr sagt
dass ihr überhaupt kein hohler habt
bekommt ihr zehn minuten später wieder
die frage willst du nicht doch das und
das essen ich könnte für dich auch das
und das kochen was ich damit meine ist
das hier also wenn wir glaube ich das
ganze essen annehmen würden dann sehe
ich jetzt nicht mehr so aus sondern so
und viele sagen ja immer der grund für
übergewicht ist mcdonald's burger king
und so da kann ich euch beruhigen also
dazu würde ich erst mal sagen das könnte
vielleicht auch einen anderen grund
haben ja und jetzt bitte noch nicht
wegschalten ich hab euch hier nochmal
den yasin verlinkt check das auf jeden
fall mal aber ich finde da hätte auf
jeden fall mehr abonnenten verdient als
2000 deswegen geht aus einem kanal
lassen aber da will ich auf jeden fall
freuen
ansonsten falls ihr vielleicht
irgendwann mal im zweiten teil sehen
wollt ihr uns recht gibt einfach noch
nach oben oder schreibt es in die
kommentare und instagram von mir ist
hier verlinkt in der beschreibung
natürlich auch und hier auf der linken
seite geht es weiter mit meinem netz
video das war hat waren das hier so ein
halloween special und hier auf der
anderen seite banken herein dinge die
jungs ein mädchen ich verschiedene
ansonsten wünsche ihnen ein schönes
wochenende und yahoo 3
bis nächste woche